remember when Tom Brady himself tried to
get Kevin Durant to join the Boston
Celtics Duran's decision to leave the
Thunder was nothing less than shocking
and multiple teams saw this as their
chance to compete for a title including
Boston free agent pitching is a common
thing in sports but usually teams bring
in former greats from their franchise
Boston knew something significant had to
take place for Durant to take his talent
to the Celtics and the Goat of football
almost convinced him Kevin Durant
recalled having a conversation with him
saying he was ready to go after hearing
what it means to win in Boston at the
same time Durant was focused very much
on the actual basketball side of things
and expressed that Brady couldn't help
him on the court his decision was just
about basketball and we all know what
happened next that summer he went on to
break the balance of the NBA by joining
a 73-9 Warriors team who had just
previously lost the final series the
season before Durant aided Golden State
in winning two titles for the franchise
along with receiving two Finals MVP
awards Kevin Durant's decision worked in
his favor but who knows how many more
championships the Celtics would have if
Tom Brady came through with his sales
pitch